yet another Funeral for a victim of
chera this time in chesa north of the
capital
Harari for us it is painful with this
disease we could not even see his face
for the last time we don't feel that we
gave him the last respect he died of
chera and the disease could spread from
here and it is spreading with at least
10 people who attended this funeral
reporting symptoms of the disease within
days the government said is it's
concerned such Gatherings are worsening
the outbreak last year it limited the
number of people attending burials and
other public Gatherings about 300 people
have died since February last year a
quarter passed away in the last month
alone after suffering from symptoms like
diarrhea vomiting and
weakness so far 16,000 people have
contracted the waterborne disease the
government says it's working to increase
supplies of clean water and it's begun
cleaning up sewage and refuges in public
areas but it's been unable to stop
Street vendors from selling food that
some fear could worsen the spread of the
disease the government says it's doing
what it can to keep people safe we don't
have enough vaccines to cover the whole
country but we have mapped out the
districts that are affected where we
would Target vaccination and we' have
come up with a Target population of um
1.9 something million so we have just
rounded it up to say we we require about
2 million doses but the World Health
Organization says Global supplies of
oral chalera vaccines are limited the
chalera outbreak is also affected
neighboring Zambia since October more
than 6,200 people have become infected
and about 250 have died it's important
that the community response becomes
stronger I think that's where there is a
weakness the community still takes it
you know easy I saw many young young men
walking me they are already
infected in mmek more than 8,200
infections have been reported and with
tens of thousands of Migrant workers
returning from Zimbabwe to South Africa
following the Christmas holidays Health
authorities have increased screening at
Borders to try and stop the spread
famida Mala Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer